hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
ich möchte heute einen op correo kuchen
machen und zwar ist der kuchen aus dem
galileo beitrag nach dem ganz viele von
euch gefragt haben und ich finde dieser
kuchen passt auch jetzt perfekt zum
heißen wetter denn der backofen bleibt
aus die küche bleibt kalt und ich habe
dann später einen richtig leckeren
kuchen der auch wirklich total
erfrischend ist und ich sage jetzt
einfach mal alle zutaten einige davon
werde ich jetzt gleich im kühlschrank
stellen
aber ich zeige es euch jetzt erst mal
alle zusammen also für den brösel boden
brauche ich 100 gramm butter die habe
ich bereits verlassen den top und habt
ihr etwas abkühlen lassen dann habe ich
hier 200 gramm oreo kekse können
natürlich auch andere kekse benutzen
aber ich und europäische ziemlich lecker
zum belegen nehme ich jetzt noch zwei
bananen für die creme brauche ich 500
gramm speisequark also magerquark 200 g
schlagsahne ein päckchen schokoküsse die
kleinen habe ich da jetzt ihr könnt auch
die großen nehmen
es ist egal dann brauche ich etwas
seiner part für die sahne zum fest
werden und später könnte a und frauen
noch eine bio zitrone genau die schale
davon und später könnte zum dekorieren
paar beeren nehmen paar kekse oder zum
beispiel auch smarties oder andere
süßigkeiten
das darf dann bei uns dieser mehrere
später einfach entscheiden
ja das habe im rat obmann weil
eigentlich kann es auch dem hochrad
machen und jeder mann sogar weil manche
regionen pause also ja also ich hab es
nicht sagt weil ich finde sich ich finde
männer könne auch gebacken
jobs wollte ich jetzt noch mal gesagt
haben so jetzt gebe ich zuerst mal die
kekse in einem mixer ihr könnt es
natürlich auch im gefrierbeutel machen
aber so geht's schnell und vor allem
wenn ihr dem ausbau starb auf einen
gefrierbeutel bauen mist bei der
temperatur fängt gleich an zu schwitzen
und hier halten wird
und jetzt gebe ich da direkt die
flüssige butter mit rein
und dann nehme ich mir jetzt einen
tortenring mit 20 cm durchmesser
ihr könnt aber auch zum beispiel eine
springform nehmen und die mit etwas bei
papier aus
natürlich muss ich auch hier jetzt den
bug rahmen auskleiden
als wir gerade unten einschlagen
und das ganze sitzt bei mir auch so
einem torten retter und hier kann ich
jetzt diese fixe butter master erfüllen
und dann 1 boden eben schon flach
drücken
man könnte so printz uhr nehmen und
irgendwie hat das können wir auch machen
weil prinz prinzenrolle habe ich so
etwas noch nie gemacht aber ich glaube
mit diesem schock kennen das ist
bestimmt lecker wie gesagt man nimmt
einfach irgendwelche kekse die lieblings
kekse butterkekse biscuit geht alles bei
dem hat mal den schönen effekt mit drin
hat sich mit diesem kontrast von weißer
creme schwarzer sport zum teig
und den boden stellte jetzt endlauf
entweder für eine halbe stunde in den
kühlschrank oder für eine viertelstunde
also wie 15 minuten ins gefrierfach
das mache ich jetzt schnell und dann
geht es gleich weiter der prüft boden
ist es gut durch gekühlt aber ich habe
ihnen immer noch im gefrierfach
gefrierfach denn ich möchte jetzt
erstmal die creme zu bereiten
dafür schlage ich jetzt erst die sahne
steif und ich mache das jetzt mal mit so
einem handrührgerät weil ich eine
ziemlich kleine menge ist mache ich
übrigens immer mit seinem spritzschutz
gespritzt so raus und da gebe ich dann
gleich zwei teelöffel sonderfahrt mit
rein
ihr wisst ja also ich sag ja auch manche
sachen öfter und wiederholt es immer
aber ich habe auch immer neue zuschauer
sahen apart nehme ich ja ganz gerne als
dann steigt mittel weil es einfach vegan
ist also ich hab keine tierischen
produkte mitbringen und die sahne wird
hat sofort fest und ich kann sie direkt
weiterverarbeiten also anders als bei
gelatine oder zum beispiel akademie und
da gebe ich jetzt gleich während dem
früheren zwei teelöffel mit rein
als nächstes nämlich jetzt den quark und
gebt ihn in eine große schüssel durch
die sahne habe ich übrigens schon kalt
gestellt denn ist schon einfach zu warm
und wenn ihr die sahne steif schlagen
könnt ihr euch zum beispiel ist so wie
hier zum kühlkette unterlegen sagen
gerinnt sie nämlich nach hitlers auch
eine herausforderung sein zu schlagen
hier gebe ich den abrieb von der
zitronenschale mit rein muss natürlich
eine bio zitrone sein arzt darf nicht
gespritzt sein
man könnte die schale immer schön
verwenden und übrigens ich euch
wahrscheinlich auch aufgefallen dass ich
jetzt keinen zucker mit drin hab sind
hierbei gleich die mohrenköpfe mit rein
und die haben schon genug süße und daher
braucht man bei dem rezept echt keinen
extra zusätzlichen zucker und das bringt
hier so ein bisschen frische mit rein
dann nehmt ihr die mohrenköpfe und die
gibt es jetzt auch mit rein allerdings
mit der jetzt da vorher diese waffen
entfernen und könnt diese köpfe dann
direkt mit rein geben
und diese waffeln die können sie
entweder später mit zur dekoration
benutzen oder er ist halt einfach auf
also ich wette später einfach aufessen
denn ich finde am morgen kommt frisches
lakers diese waffe und ich mag diese
creme gar zu gern bei murat ist anders
strom deswegen krieg ich oft von ihm die
waffe und er kriegt halt da gab es im
kopf haben unser wissen die kalorien
geteilt er kriegt kalorien nicht
eigentlich nur die waffe aber na ja ich
gebe jetzt hier auch direkt sonderfahrt
mit rein mit vier esslöffel teelöffel
esslöffel bei zufriedenstellen wird es
jetzt auch kurz verrührt ob es damals
könnte auch erste besitzer drücke
jetzt kennt er direkt die sahne
unterheben bei mir etwas flüssiger aber
das macht nichts denn ich habe seiner
partnerin und die quarkcreme ist sowieso
schon fest und das ist noch kurz
unterheben
es hat echt tolle aromen die sich jetzt
verbinden ganz ganz lecker das stelle
ich kurz zur seite
aber am besten mit dem kühlpads den wie
gesagt verstehen dass er war dann kann
ich mir auch direkt den kuchen
rausnehmen und nehme jetzt noch hier
zwei bananen
denn da bringen jetzt einfach so bittel
obst mit rein die werden jetzt geschält
und dann einfach in scheiben geschnitten
und drüber gelegt und weil sie dann
unter dieser prämisse ist auch nicht mit
zitronensaft irgendwie behandeln damit
sie jetzt nicht brauchen werden weil die
finnen schon geschützt
und dann kommt da jetzt diese leckere
creme einfach oben drauf
wer jetzt könnt ihr wenn ihr wollt das
ganze noch schön glatt streichen mit so
einer kleinen palette und im prinzip
finde ich das gar nicht so die
kalorienbombe weil eigentlich gut wenn
man sich jetzt die häufigste butterweck
denkt und die sahne und diese
schaumküsse dann hat mein banane und
quark und das ist ja relativ zum hat der
weiße seite von daher finde ich es auch
eine leichte beute
ironie aus und die stelle jetzt nochmal
in den kühlschrank und zwar für etwa
eine stunde ihr könnt ihr auch gerne
wieder ins gefrierfach stellen ab oder
wenn ihr jetzt so was wie eine eistorte
volt können das auch länger ins
gefrierfach stellen haben richtig kalte
torte aber ich möchte es später so als
sahne quark creme deswegen nur im
kühlschrank und später darf dann jeder
kommen und es ganz richtig schön
dekoriert
jetzt ist unser kuchen schön kalt und
ich selbst sehen direkt auf eine
tortenplatte und jetzt kann ich auch das
backpapier unten absehen denn der teig
bohren ist schönfeld
natürlich jetzt nehme ich einen
tortenring messer vom vater einmal
entlang
damit kann ich jetzt den tortenring
ablöst
und witti korean den kuchen jetzt noch
fertig mit ein paar keksen und
brombeeren
jetzt kann ich die torte anschneiden des
angebots übrigens zu warm hier in der
küche deswegen ist sie in ihrem zimmer
verschwunden
kühler und ihr habt ja jetzt praktisch
diese oreo kekse als orientierung und
wissen jetzt wie ihr die schneiden
müssen
also die torte ich eigentlich etwas
fester nur hier drin jetzt gerade wieder
keine ahnung 35 grad in meiner küche und
deswegen ist jetzt schon wieder etwas
weicher ich muss jetzt auch gleich
wieder kühl stellen aber ich finde die
torte sieht nicht nur toll aus
geschmeckt hat auch richtig gut aber ihr
wisst ich probiere gerne vor der kamera
und sah mir schmeckt also das probiert
ich finde zwischen super tolles rezept
gerade an warmen tagen weil ihr den
backofen nicht an machen müsst und wenn
ihr nicht so wie bei mir die jalousien
hoch machen müsst wegen dem video liegt
dann ist auch die küche kühl und dann
steht die torte auch richtig schön und
ihr könnt das rezept einfach nachlesen
ob cellestis blog.de und wir sehen uns
dann ganz einfach das nächste mal wieder
abonniert mal aus kanada
ja ja
mamas